ne pleure pas Marie tu jouis comme tout
mais j'aime pas les cheveux courts ça
casse tout le glamour j'étais une parano
depuis le premier jour à l'aéroport
alors aujourd'hui vous le faites quoi et
comment vous vous sentez en fait avant
de faire la télé j'étais déjà infirmière
infirmière de bloc opératoire donc j'ai
dû me séparer de ce travail pour
m'orienter vers du libéral parce que
j'étais beaucoup trop reconnue au bloc
opératoire et puis ben aujourd'hui
toujours infirmière pour infirmière
libérale mais je vis toujours les
conséquences de la téléréalité on
reconnaît toujours énormément déjà je
suis toujours reconnu dans la rue sauf
que avant
j'étais aduler aujourd'hui je me fais
insulter tous les noms
infirmière était les réalités ça ne va
pas ensemble tout simplement donc ça
vous avez des patients qui vous le
disent que vous arrivez parfois mais en
fait j'ai des patients qui ont changé
d'infirmière carrément retourner dans la
lumière plus jamais je suis encore
malheureusement dans la lumière mais
dans la mauvaise lumière